I'm pretty sure that nowadays it's like
in a contract somewhere that if Adam
Sandler is in a movie it has to also
start David Spade Steve Buscemi and
Kevin James it's like some sort of
requirement somewhere I know it it must
be Hotel Transylvania is not a film I
was looking forward to it just it looks
so generic to me lately anymore when
Adam Sandler is attached to something
it's not good anymore which is
unfortunate because I've always liked
him this is an animated 3d tale for the
family it's about Count Dracula he
starts Hotel Transylvania it's a place
where monsters can go and have sanctuary
away from humans who are the villains
because humans throughout history have
always burned monsters and used
pitchforks and killed them and so humans
are actually the villains now his young
daughter Mavis voiced by Selena Gomez
she wants to go out and find the humans
she wants to go out and see what
everything's like it's her a hundred and
18th birthday that's all she wants to do
now just by random chance a backpacking
kid who was mountain climbing a human
stumbles across this hotel and goes
inside Count Dracula realizes he's a
human before anyone else does he has to
try to keep him away from everyone and
make him look like a monster so no one's
you know frightened by him and of course
little Mavis falls for the human now
like I said I had no expectations for
this movie at all and I really wasn't
even like I was just like whatever this
movie actually was freaking hilarious
I laughed quite often in this movie I
couldn't believe it and you want to know
what the biggest surprise of this movie
was for me besides the fact that I
actually really enjoyed it this movie's
directed by genndy tartakovsky the
creator of Dexter's Laboratory Samurai
Jack Powerpuff Girls and the good Clone
Wars miniseries how did I not know that
that guy's like my favorite animation
director I mean he made like all these
great cartoons that I loved as a kid no
wonder I enjoyed this movie and at the
exact same feel as Dexter's Laboratory
did really really fast paced really
oddball quirky humor like just random
things you would never expect to see in
a family movie we're in this movie
entertaining characters really good 3d
and CGI animation and some good songs
too and yes Adam saying they're saying
some of the songs and that's always
entertaining for me because I've always
liked his singing also working in this
movie is the musical score now it's one
of those great musical scores like
Looney tune
ones where the music matches everything
perfectly that happens really really
loud score how I can Space Jam you know
every time someone turns around there's
like a it's one of those really loud and
intense scores for kids movies that is
purposely meant to like propel the story
along really well and I really enjoyed
it the voice acting across the board is
really good but you know I was really
surprised how good Adam Sandler was as
Count Dracula because I've never really
seen him do too much voice acting I
didn't see eight crazy nights Steve
Buscemi especially was one of my
favorite characters he plays a werewolf
with like eight hundred children but the
best part of this movie is that it has
an entire scene dedicated to ripping
Twilight yes I mean the audience
actually applauded I was like thank
goodness I'm in a semi smart theater now
they actually took the time to make an
entire scene dedicated to Twilight hate
thank you my only problem is really with
the movie is it's not a film with loads
and loads of emotional substance it has
the requirements you know it has what
you need it's got the meet of emotion in
it it's just it's not like you know Toy
Story or something where you're just
gonna be like oh my god I hope
everything's okay it's just a really
fast paced and fun movie I really
enjoyed the film I'm gonna give it a B+
thanks as always guys and if you like
this and you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes
[Music]